today we're gonna eat pizza guess which
ones expensive which ones cheap
you're welcome I love pizza I'm gonna
say I don't know if I love it as much as
my right here I keep so like pretty
often I wouldn't say like all the time
I feel like pizza is one of those foods
that are always free somewhere so you're
always eating pizza I also have this
lovely tattoo here
it's a pepperoni and jalapeno my
favorite toppings I will say this
toppings I don't know you that well but
I hope that you don't put pineapple but
thank you thank you thank you all say he
loves pizza I'm very confident I mean
I'm pretty confident here I'm not gonna
lie I mean there's a big dude who knows
his flavors and his food say like you're
not gonna be able to give me that that
much all right let's try this pizza
let's do it all right Bon Appetit blown
Appetit let's do a cheer so I can like
feel my face getting greasy just eating
this but so good it doesn't have a lot
of sauce mmm I think the lack of sauce
makes it now make me think that's
cheaper mm-hmm because you know I'll
give you a little a restaurant like
legit pizza place they take you know
pride yes ah sweet this is some like
quality pepperoni no you can tell cuz
they throw does that mean it's good meat
oh I remember that mean that's fate you
know one like plastic heats up and just
roll I'm spillin he did we didn't had
lunch today so that's the thing about
pizza even bad pizza you just can't go
wrong with it the crust is really hard I
don't know what that means
maybe it means it's good we just won't
ever know until the end of the video
it's not bad overall I don't taste any
spices there's no sauce which since
there's no spices I'm probably happy
about the sauce because I'm a tea master
but I feel like this is the cheaper work
I think this was more on the expensive
end yeah I can't really tell you it I
feel like I have to try the other pizzas
I agree with Jackie I think we have to
try the other ones first I think so look
how cute she is
it looks like easy-bake pizza oh maybe
it is an easy big pizza is this an easy
big pizza is this really an easy bake
pizza this was just kind of looks sad
look depressed it's gotten to assign to
it yeah you know yeah you want to shine
won't be the one oh this is fake oh it's
good
others like pizza it got the sauce I was
looking for there's a nice little crisp
on the press it reminds me of like pizza
hope this isn't pics across just because
I know they're cross this is their crust
you know if you guys tell me otherwise
right there y'all are wrong because I
know this is the crust this is like that
just almost middle to a little bit but I
think my guess is that this is cheap
pizza really I think this is still the
medium price Pete took but also I'm
really stupid so let's just find out my
god
this one piece de la rose' stars clearly
it's like the size of someone's face and
have a bigger space that was smashing
down a subway this is quite a pizza
I don't even smells weird it smells kind
of funky this smells like it's been in
it back did you put it in your backpack
I do want to say though the cheese is
kind of throwing me off it is they kind
of failed with the cheesy whoever layer
of this cheese should be talked to her
too much sauce not enough cheese right
off the bat I mean I'm getting a lot of
tomato sauce eNOS yeah but you know what
I like about this one they like put some
love into the sauce here this is a
little Caesar sauce it tastes cheap
biosocial they're so sweet that's sweet
do you think people would be mad if I
started eating it down the middle please
don't do that
I don't know why it bothers me but deal
with it oh my god I still feel like this
one despite his taste
overall I feel like he might be the most
expensive I just don't like the sauce it
tasted very strange I think this is the
cheapest yeah and the fact that like the
sauce is really sweet says that they put
a lot of sugar in there I feel like
that's a sign of something that's cheap
you know what I just thought about you
know why it's so sweet the sauce comes
pineapple in there I just thought about
it I'm like why is it so sweet people
have like chocolate is fine I think this
one's a cheap minute on my first choice
like that's the middle most expensive
pizza really I'm telling you I know I
have like a sixth sense about this kind
of stuff I mean you got the pizza tattoo
are my glass you know questioners medium
range but up wrong cheapest this is
definitely the cheapest Oh surprised me
a little bit but as always pizza House
dinner it delivers it no pun intended
[Music]
that's a lot less tax he's ten dollars
look at the cheese you're making this is
no cheese it looked like a picture of
the Earth from space I mean it's huge it
is pretty big but I guess yeah you know
you pay for what you get I mean the only
one they got me on was the cheapest in
the middle all right oh I got nothing
right no your dad you got this what do
you say fellas yo I got him all right I
should take you to eat some good peeks
around here so you're not all this thing
where they have cheese and sauce yes and
spices yeah ah you don't say at the end
of the day we all win because we got to
eat pizza I mean they're probably eating
pizza while they're watching us
likely I mean the man got a tattoo
pingzhi so he got a nice I think yeah I
mean you just can't he got a film reel
and pizza so if the man got movie
recommendations or pizza spots I'm not
gonna ask you any question it's all you
need to know and there you have it
[Music]